today's video is about subdividing
triangles and possibly indications of
how such subdivisions happen in higher
dimensional analogues of triangles so we
start with a triangle and we use a
subdivision that is classic in
mathematics the pericentric subdivisions
this could be any triangle basically
this could be any triangle but for the
time being let's let's be as an
equilateral triangle we want to
subdivide the area of this triangle into
smaller pieces the per Centric
subdivision proceeds as follows in order
to subdivide it we need more vertices
first and the vertices here we get by
looking at the so-called phases of the
object so faces are the vertices the
edges and the whole triangle and for
each of those we take the Barry Center
which is like the center point in a in a
certain sense the sum of the vertices
divided by the number of vertices
and for the actual vertices this is just
the vertex itself for an edge it's the
midpoint of this Edge and then we have
the very center of the whole triangle
somewhere here and now we need to know
how to draw the edges of the new
triangle and we need a rule for that and
the rule is that we connect two vertices
of this new set of vertices if the
corresponding faces are contained in
each other so for example we keep this
Edge from here to here
so this is now a single edge because
this is the center point of this Edge
which contains this vertex
we also have an edge from here to here
because this vertex is part of the whole
triangle
we have no Edge from here to here
because this vertex is not contained in
this Edge
so we continue with that so this one is
we have an edge here because this Edge
is contained in the whole triangle and
so on so this is the pericentric
subdivision of this triangle we got six
new triangles you can continue you can
now
uh start subdividing again to a new
refinement like now you go to each of
those triangles you do the same thing
subdivide you can do this to each of
these six
again subdivide
and you get a finer and finer set of
triangles
which covers the original area of these
triangles you were telling me there
might be a problem with this well it
depends on what purpose you are doing
that for
I mean one purpose you could do is an
applied purpose you have many triangles
that say try to approximate a shape you
model some monster in a movie
your original set of triangles is too
coarse there are too many edges in your
monster and you want to have it more
smooth and then you try to do this by
having smaller and smaller triangles
now if you do paracentric subdivision
one of the disadvantages of this
subdivision is that the angles in these
triangles they become more and more
acute or obtuse so here you have a very
acute try and hear even more and so on
so the angles become uneven the
triangles tend to be kind of lengthy and
that's not what you want usually if you
want to model for mathematical purposes
the percent accept division is perfectly
fine there are very many applications in
mathematics of percentage subdivisions
of triangles higher dimensional
simplices and so on this alternative is
the so-called edgewise subdivision so
now again we need first to create a new
set of vertices and the way we create
this new set of vertices here is a
different one
so I will draw a little second picture
which now is supposed to be in three
space these are the coordinate axis of
three-dimensional space and now I place
exactly this triangle here in this
position so the coordinates now of these
three points are one in the X Direction
zero in the y direction and zero in the
set Direction and here I get zero in the
X Direction one in the y direction zero
in this set Direction and then here have
0 0 1. and now I choose a number R and I
dilate this triangle by this number r
so let's for example take
R equals to three this point now is
three zero zero this point here is
somewhere here zero three zero this
point here now being zero zero three on
this new triangle there are no more
points with integer coordinates on this
line here we also have the point with
coordinates one two zero and the point
with coordinates two one zero and then
there is a point somewhere here in the
middle which has coordinates one one so
this gives us our new set of points that
in the original barycentric subdivision
we had obtained by taking Barry centers
so let me draw these points now here so
now for R equals to 3 so the number we
have chosen is a kind of degree of
freedom for the subdivision
and now this vertex becomes like three
zero zero this one is zero three zero
and this zero zero three so this is
these correspondence between the
triangle right here and the triangle
I've drawn here and then we draw the
additional vertices these are these
integer points here from these lines
copied and then the point in the middle
one one one okay now again we need a
rule how to connect these points
in order to form the new triangles why
do we need a row how come I I can't just
do it by eye like it's not you know I
couldn't just join all the dots yeah
actually in if you if you want to create
a very even subdivision then prob
there's a good guess and the good guess
is this one is a triangle this one here
is a triangle this is a triangle lens on
it that will be the edgewise subdivision
you could as well take for example a
triangle this way that's also a
possibility or even a very strange
triangle like hearing edge here and here
so you need also a mathematical rule for
doing this and the actual need for that
rule is more apparent if you go to
higher Dimensions if you subdivide
simplistis for example a tetrahedra and
even higher dimensional objects so as I
look at this it all seems pretty obvious
but you're creating all this rigor
because later on there'll be times when
it's not obvious what dots to join
that's exactly true yes so you change
these coordinates slightly now instead
of three zero zero you replace this by
you take the first coordinate which is
three then you add the first two
coordinates is zero plus three is three
and then you add all coordinates which
again gives three
you do this here too you start with a
two the next sum is two plus one is
three two plus one plus zero is three
one is copied one plus two is three one
plus two plus zero is three here the
zero is copied zero plus three is three
zero three and then another three and
this one here you replace by one two
three one one plus one one plus one plus
one and so on and now the rule is that
you take these new coordinates and you
subtract them from each other for
example you you pick this vertex and
this vertex there you have three 3 3 for
this vertex you subtract 1 2 3 and the
difference is taking coordinate device
you take three minus 1 is 2 3 minus two
is one and three minus three is zero so
you get this two one zero okay but you
could also take for example this vertex
and this vertex so you get three three
minus two three three which then is
three minus two is one three minus three
is zero three minus three is zero okay
the rule says do not connect the two
vertices that yield two one zero but the
ones that we yield one zero zero and the
reason is you want the difference only
uses once minus ones and zeros indeed
you want that the difference is either a
combination of ones and zeros or a
combination of minus ones and zeros so
this is not okay this is okay and if you
interchange the role of the two then it
would be -1 0 0 and again that would be
okay so it's almost like using this
alternative number each pair of
coordinates has like sort of a code a
relationship between them and if that
relationship number this number
is one contains only ones only zeros or
minus ones you join them that's right if
you now apply this rule you will get the
picture you would have guessed from the
beginning
this is the picture Okay so this yields
nine triangles
and you see they're all actually
congruent it's all the same triangles if
you had started from an essay
equilateral try yeah and presumably this
is just a perfect thing it can't work
out any other way that you ever get ones
and zeros that shouldn't be joined and
that's right it's an if and only if
and if you'd used a different number
other than three and you had lots and
lots of Divisions along these lines same
rule applies the same rule applies just
the number of triangles increases
so the number of triangles you get is
always this number r squared in in
general if you go into a higher
Dimensions like you do this and apply
this to say a tetrahedron that's the
next Dimension so that would be a
three-dimensional object you would get R
cubed many new tetrahedra in general you
get R to the D many new triangle or
higher dimensional analogs of triangles
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
Works a tree and what and the advantage
of this is we seem to get more
friendly triangles do we that's right
that's right we get more friendly
triangles it's more evenly distributed
um you get uh you get in two Dimensions
you get only if you start with an a
lateral triangle you only get a
congruent triangles in the next
Dimension you get a small number of
congruent simplices and that's also for
higher Dimension is you can control how
many different incongruent objects you
get and you also can control the
deviation of their shape so you've shown
me two Dimensions triangles but you've
also alluded to the fact this works in
higher Dimensions we could get like a
Simplex like a three-dimensional object
and divide that up into three 3D pieces
could we
that's right yeah I mean the the 3D
Simplex that's the tetrahedron so we
have four numbers for that will we for
the Hy subdivision we have four numbers
for Simplicity let's choose here R
equals to two otherwise we end up with
too many dots and it becomes hard to
visualize so that means that now we
place in order to get this picture here
we place this tetrahedron in four space
so in a four dimensional space
and with the vertices being the unit
coordinate vectors yeah and then dilate
this by two
so we end up with this for example being
two zero zero zero this being zero two
zero zero zero zero two zero zero zero
zero two and then we get these new
vertices like that one for example that
would be a one zero zero one in the
middle of each line in the middle of
each line yeah and then because R is
small R is two we don't get any
additional point in the middle like here
you get something in the interior of
this triangle and here you get nothing
in the interior of each face and also
nothing in the interior of the whole
tetrahedron if R is three we get some in
an additional point in the interior of
every these triangles and if R is four
we would get a point in the middle but
now let's apply this rule it's already a
bit more tricky so here you do of course
the same on each face so that's the easy
rule essentially we have seen in
dimension two but now this is not yet a
subdivision into tetrahedra I mean you
see here there is a tetrahedron sitting
on top a tetrahedra sitting on the front
the tetrahedron sitting here but then in
the middle you have this object which is
actually an octahedron and you need to
further subdivide it and for that
suddenly this Edge becomes important you
need to connect those two vertices and
in order to get this subdivide in
tetrahedra you draw another edge here in
the middle this new Edge now serves as
an edge that subdivides this octahedron
into four tetrahedron when I'm doing a
subdivision here and I'm using your
magic rule you showed me here with the
you know transferring the coordinates
and then subtracting them is it still
the ones the ones and the minus ones I'm
looking for to decide when to make a
joint exactly so you you you may get
transformation of these coordinates the
same way we did before you take the
first coordinate then add the first two
at the first three at the first four and
then you subtract these new coordinates
from each other if the resulting Vector
is a zero one vector or it's a zero
minus one vector then you connect them
by image
okay presumably you can have multiple
ones and you know it could be have it
didn't have
does it only ever have one one or can I
have multiple ones it can have multiple
yeah it's made of only ones and it's all
made of only ones but it's not
permissible to have one n minus one that
that would not be permissible it's just
either one in zero or minus one in zero
so for sort of a computer programmer or
a modeler or an animator or someone they
would prefer to subdivide their
triangles using this method presumably
yes yes
you're not one of those people you're a
pure mathematician that's right what do
you like to use do you prefer this
veracentric or do you like these
edgewise I mean both are good in both
serve different purposes so in in
mathematics I mean the very Centric
subdivision is a is a classical object
that is used in algebraic topology and
serves there for many purposes the
edgewise subdivision
also actually came from algebraic
topology but has also many applications
in combinatorics algebraic topology and
other fields you've shown me two ways to
subdivide a triangle today are there
other ways yeah there are very many
different ways you can just imagine like
you can combine the edgewise and the
pericentric subdivision like you first
subdivide say paracentrically and then
subdivide each triangle edgewise by some
R but you can also do different things
as I shown you before I mean the the
fact that we ever choosing this edge
here instead of this edge here this was
in order to make our triangles as even
as possible but mathematically it's also
okay to remove this Edge and instead
have this Edge so there are many ways
you can do flips on these triangles on
these edges to create new ways of
subdividing your original triangle you
were talking earlier about a practical
application you were talking about
rendering a monster in a movie or
something but mathematicians are doing
this just purely for abstract purposes
just for for research and to create new
mathematics out like there's like
there's just weird places you go with
this that's right I mean we have many
questions many questions are have been
answered but there are also many
questions that are open about these
objects so uh the this the complete
understanding of the structure of the
number of faces that appear when you do
this iteratively for very Centric
subdivision or Hy subdivision has only
been unraveled in the last 20 years and
there are still open questions even
though the objects look pretty simple
can there be new ways to subdivide or
that are useful or do you think pretty
much all the ways to subdivide a
triangle are known now or I I think you
can always come up with a new way of
subdividing if you have a new question
if there can be new mathematical
questions where those two methods are
not good for in their new new methods
for subdivision needed to solve these
questions
it's exciting I'd love to come up with a
new subdivision myself you call it the
Brady subdivision okay I we gladly can
work on that all right let's let's go
upstairs and sort it out okay let's go
uh they're superhero trying these are
our superhero triangles absolutely I've
now given you permission to put click
bait thumbnails on this video get
Captain America over here I can't
believe it superhero triangles which one
is the actual center of the triangle
there is no actual Center it depends on
your viewpoint